hey guys welcome to behind the scenes
for the Superman video now before we
tell you how he pulled off all these
amazing shots we're gonna tell you first
off how you can win one of these things
this is Taylor CEO of John fly calm they
sell these things the Phantom - awesome
quadrocopter let's get sweet shots you
guys want to win one we're giving one
away in order to win your own phantom -
all you have to do is go to our Facebook
page facebook.com slash board or digital
and then go to the Superman video and
hit share on that sucker and we will
pick one person randomly who will share
that video and one day you will get this
in the mail
hopefully that day is very soon all
right on to the video
so to get the shots we got in one of
those real helicopters and stuck out the
camera out the window this is the DJI
phantom 2 you can get them on drone fly
calm this is what's letting us get all
the sweet superman shots basically what
it is it's a quadrocopter it's
stabilized so you can fly it around it
hovers does all the cool things that you
expect a quadrocopter to do it flies to
GoPro and that GoPro is actually on a
little gimbal here a 2 axis gimbal that
stabilizes the GoPro and this is really
what's letting us do the Superman shots
we're going actually slow and as smooth
as we can and the GoPro is being kept as
smooth as it possibly can be with this
gimbal then later on post
we're speeding it all up stabilizing it
and getting that Superman look it
actually has a GPS built in so for
example if it loses signal can fly back
to you also another interesting thing is
there is a video transmitter here so
we're not just flying blind we actually
can look at a screen and see what's
happening whoa Wow for like ground
transition shots like we'd have somebody
wearing a GoPro and they jump or do
their thing beat up some bad guys and
we'd fly the quadrocopter right from
that point where the person where cuts
and a little bit of jiggle the GoPro
would cover up the the cut point and it
takes off into the air and fly the
quadrocopter up into the air
so as you can see it's super stable and
it gives us the kind of control we need
to actually get like Superman shots you
want as much flying dumpster as possible
remember lastly through almost all into
that bridge house real offline
oh yeah just laugh ya see it it
literally landed in the one dry spot man
that thing is so smart
yet it was crazy
I want to under the bridge not sure I
lost connection for a little bit and
then raised it up and regain control and
brought back and I think we got the shot
hopefully we're all about pushing
Taylor's limits here um this building
measuring bunch of smoke coming from
this area so the buildings on fire just
going to swoop by um drone will kind of
look at you when this doing that you're
like waving out like help me save me you
don't need an vocalize just you know
move your arms and stuff as soon as the
students I'm out of its view I can just
read exactly and then it comes back and
then a green screen l and go like oh off
the building and it goes includes a
green screen element and then cuts into
actual first person GoPro on a green
screen
we're flying looks like thank you so bad
and then on the landing we're actually
cutting back into real life again where
we actually are going to land on the
ground
GoPro Neko is gonna be super it's gonna
have super arms but be super efficient
then the landing the drone comes down
and then we cut on the impact so cuts
into actual GoPro whoo here we go
thanks for saving me okay peace and then
cuts back in the drone app again icon go
ahead
any against
I hope this works okay you're haunted by
way three high APB says we got - perps
running down traction Avenue we have in
evidence they might have went to Allah
any better I'm all alone out there so I
hope they don't run me and I don't have
and I hope that they don't have superior
firepower otherwise I'm gonna find
myself in a bit of a scenario he's got
to punch the guns out of everyone's
hands he is well I mean yeah well then
get me is holded yeah I don't get
everything every something where so I
come up to you and just just turn the
gun out sideways more of a criminal gun
actually matching track pants yeah we
figure if you're gonna commit a crime
you have to be able to do lunges so
Supes lines there and you guys are
running and there's a cop behind you and
you're like oh
he's gonna start walking towards you
lettin pic take you steps
oh [ __ ] what are you gonna do have to
shoot him so hey big thing like two
three seconds of shooting and then your
broth outta ammo fly it
zip yeah yeah you can be empty but you
can still hold it up man what'd you do
that Superman broke a stable GoPro how
was that last one
it was funny I think it wasn't that bad
but when I grabbed the gun it didn't
break ease it's like there's a cloudy
day doesn't have a ton of strength right
now by the time I hear her giggle it
means it's over Francois Truffaut's
they're like this got actually tore it
into may just close it in the middle
look you need me got it
I think we got it let's finish off the
drone in Diego check it let's finish
this off with the drone we should do
more GoPro shoots
so chill
no holes where are we as opposed to LAX
you know if they fly over here things I
went the photo so anyway I tried the
door next min you'll take the GoPro off
your head okay
any of the bag you like I think I belong
this belongs to you and then you toss it
over to him I'm like see that's that was
a taste action
the camera
on this card lies the power and strength
of an entire day of filming it is sacred
because of that we're trying to get cool
shots with this this drone that's the
whole point of the video just Superman
flying in cool places and oddly enough
even though we have full control over
where this camera is flying there's a
few challenges we are facing
we're speeding of the footage up a ton
and so that means each time we film a
shot everything has to be very very
smooth and precise and the gimbal helps
do that a ton but the other half of that
is just practicing the shots making sure
your piloting skills are up to par
another big one we're dealing with is
the like the length of travel were
covering in each shot because you know
the actual transmission range on the
drone is super far and it's even further
than the actual like video transmitter
so we're you know we always needing to
find that that middle ground between how
far the drone actually can fly versus
how far we can see it you know through
the monitor the worst thing actually
about trying to film this video is that
you know we want to have Superman
traveling super super fast
so we're speeding up the lot of the
shots we're doing a little stabilization
to make them seem like you just like
freaking like a jet but the issue is
that everyone on the ground isn't moving
that fast everyone's moving really slow
so when you speed up the footage all the
cars are going like 3,000 miles an hour
and everyone's going looks like little
ants running around and stuff
we're so basically we're trying to find
areas that aren't heavily populated
don't have a lot of movement on the
ground so we have total freedom to do
any like speed ramping and time
remapping in the shots so one of the
trickiest things for what Nico and Sam
required me to do while piloting the
drone was basically pulling off really
long shots and when we were up on the
roof in downtown LA we did one shot in
front of the building and then the
second shot behind the building in an
alleyway in order to do that we couldn't
do it from just one take we had to break
it up into two and so what Nico
suggested we do is just to do the
transition to stop the drone after the
first half put it in GPS mode and let it
just hold its position well we actually
walked and moved across to the behind of
the
building to do the alleyway landing
basically in the shot what ends up
happening is the first half of it plays
it goes up into a business ition and
like essentially pauses and then what we
do is we kind of hide a transition in
there where we take out a series of like
almost like twenty seconds it's up there
for like almost a half minute and we
took out that entire sequence and the
frame after those thirty seconds was
almost identical to the one where it
stopped it's all we needed to do is just
realign them a little bit and no one
will notice that's about it guys
just want to say a big thanks to Taylor
and drone fly comm Taylor is an ace
pilot this piece of not impossible
without him or his sweet drones so you
want to check them out uh go drone fly
and don't forget about the contest go to
our Facebook page share the Superman
video by clicking on the share button
and we're gonna pick one person at
random to win one of these pretty sweet
and I got your own video until then have
fun check you later yeah stay in school
that's good that's like that's a really
cool ending